but because you like reviews so many
different pieces of media I got to ask
how does anime fans rank in terms of
like toxicity compared to like gaming
movies TV shows I've always wanted to
know maybe at the bottom oh really
really and all your fans even when I
have a tech they don't like even JoJo's
it's like a couple jokes I this is we're
gonna reopen an old wound I didn't mind
the newest Terminator the one where they
just like killed John Connor off right
because like it was just fun goofy
actions like John Connor like absolutely
[ __ ] sucked in Genesis true action
salvation yeah three bad I'm fine
killing them off I got so many Reddit
threads and tweets about how [ __ ]
wrong I was
even with JoJo's no one's doing that
people watch the new Terminator movies I
thought there's just like some kind of
text like uh laundering no one that like
they're bad like they've been bad for a
while but the new one I think it's dark
fate or something along with yeah Arnold
Schwarzenegger like has a brief
appearance yeah I didn't even know
they're still making them they looked
Dreadful it looked terrible I went to
see it because I thought it would be bad
because Genesis was an unwatchable dog
[ __ ] mess it was terrible but I went to
see it and I was like I don't mind it
it's nothing but this new Terminator
this lady killing you know the basically
same Terminator from Terminator two yeah
yeah it was it was fun yeah I think
you're gonna say the gaming fans of the
most talks no it's absolutely the movie
the movie and TV shows gaming Gaming's
rough but movie and TV shows they get
rabid so the terminated I think the
worst thing that ever happened
Terminator was bad there was an entire
YouTube channel they did a two-hour
podcast dissecting how wrong
we should make this two out of all the
characters dissecting their podcast
they were so mad it was wild no one else
has done that anywhere for gaming for
and
that's so weird to hear because you know
I see some of the [ __ ] like you know
donkey gets when he basically reviews a
jrpg and I'm like I'm glad I don't have
to deal with those you know it must be
just like something with donkey they
don't like him in particular his takes
are spicy on jrpgs for sure but like I I
mean I have spicy takes on gaming too
like Red Dead Redemption I think is a
bit overrated
second one I read that Redemption too
like I think it's a bit overrated it's a
great game but the gameplay is dated
yeah needlessly tedious like it's a
great game but I think it is already
people get like mad for a minute but
then they're like whatever I still like
the game yeah they don't do that for
movies and TV they don't it's like if
you don't like it you're [ __ ] up and
here's why see because I feel coming
from like the inside the anime Community
I feel that's what the anime Community
is like to us where it's like you say
one opinion and they will hold on to
that [ __ ] for the rest of your life yeah
yeah that will never let you go for it I
mean it depends on the anime because
JoJo yeah we are like Jojo fans are very
very loud yes I feel like I think they
have a sense of humor though yeah yeah
oh yeah yeah yeah they know they're
annoying I mean it's JoJo you go of
course you guys are self-aware you watch
JoJo you know of course but like I feel
like especially with like I've seen way
more talks and seeing someone like the
more mainstream anime like Attack on
Titan fans they used to be like really
chill then ever since like season three
season four and then it got mainstream
yeah basically basically right when when
they go like super super popular yeah
that's when I saw like the toxicity just
like [ __ ] Skyrocket yeah I don't know
it's it's it's super weird and I'm not
sure what like gaming fans are like as
well does toxicity perhaps have to
correlate with how mainstream something
is
profound
the more mainstream something is the
more toxic yeah I mean but then I feel
like a lot of people just then it gets
you that it becomes so matter right
where then people will make a whole big
deal about complaining about this tiny
group of people yeah then they're just
the bigger group of the ones complaining
about the annoying yeah toxic faster and
then it becomes this whole self like
fulfilling prophecy kind of [ __ ]
where it's like yeah you just Rick and
Morty fans were a little bit annoying
but they weren't that bad like everyone
made them out to be it was like one
Reddit post and they ran with I don't
know why everyone
they like ruined Rick and Morty you
can't what you can't say you watch Rick
and Morty now otherwise you're like oh
okay haha that's so funny
yeah it was okay it's been fine it's
been a watchable it's been okay it's
fine it's good it's better than the
Simpsons like what am I going to do yeah
do you have any other like hot anime
takes then let's bring them all out
while yeah yeah so since we're going
down the hot anime takes why not give
like probably the hottest I I hated one
piece for the first for the at least the
first 80 90 episodes okay okay big big
mistake you'll first of all you're
watching
I've heard uh does it get good so I met
I finished Alabaster I'm at Skype here
now it's much better like it's
definitely improving where am I at yo
before Alabama yeah okay
um did you like Alabaster Alabaster was
much much better that was the first time
I was like this is much better yeah but
let me go ahead and explain this go on I
hate absolutely hate that they don't
kill any characters I think that is so
silly like Pell takes a bomb up into
this how far are you in Alabaster you
can say yes
there's been like moments where I'm like
okay like there was um I can't remember
it was the ark before it was when
they're on the giant Island yeah and
there was this whole like it was it was
the I was I was been reading the manga
and I hadn't really got bold with any of
it I was kind of like just I was like
okay I know it's going to get better
yeah but that was one fire I was like
yeah this feels really dated and like it
made it feel really old when they were
like fighting with the wax thing
there's a whole thing where they were
just stuck in wax and it was just like
what is this fight this is yeah well I
mean you also have to understand it's a
20 year old no right right it's like you
you read one piece and it feels old like
it it feels like a dated manga because
it would never you could never have a
manga this slow paced yeah like come out
today well that's why I'm surprised
you're actually watching it because as a
one-piece fan even I wouldn't like
advocate for watching One Piece anymore
it's the the anime is so old now and so
like slow paced it's back in the day
when it was like acceptable just to have
like filler everywhere to just drag
things on for as long as possible yeah
because there was only like what maybe
20 new series per year yeah yeah back
then so people were like more I guess
like patient I mean like [ __ ] older
you know like first or second season of
Dragon Ball episodes
is so incredibly slow it's insane like I
can't I can't imagine me being like five
years old being like this is the most
high octane [ __ ] ever if you're watching
now it's just like two big Bros just
standing there staring at each other for
20 minutes it's like nothing's [ __ ]
happening yeah I think a lot of the
reason why people would get angry at you
for that take is because I think one
piece fans have got so far you know it's
like looking at this child they look at
Rose tinted glasses like yeah I loved it
as a kid how can you not like it yeah
and you're like I love this thing so
much now there's no way the start could
have been bad yeah right because it's
like I I this is because people who like
one piece really really like one piece
and it's like their identity and they
it's everything they're obsessed with I
mean
the fact that they are like 20 plus
channels that can make a living off just
talking about one piece like name
another property where you can have that
like Naruto no no there's like two
channels bleach there's like 10 there's
like okay I'm dialing it back there's
there are a lot of channels who just
cover the manga yeah talk about the show
of fan theories who can who only do that
and can make a living oh yeah and
there's room for more than like 10. it's
crazy like no other anime you can do
that or video Maybe video game you can
actually that's League of Legends of
some shots yeah I mean I mean there's
something videos some video games that
are just like they approached as well
yeah exactly exactly I mean the one
piece I feel though
I feel like one piece is just like now
on a completely different caliber that
like it's it's very difficult to like
compare it to another manga series it's
pretty sold more accomplished in the
Bible in Japan like I I mean obviously
it has because I think I think it's like
being close if not already the top
selling like comic period yeah yeah yeah
like beating out like even like Batman
and Superman I think which is like which
is insane insane to think about that
it's it's [ __ ] one piece you know you
think about how iconic Batman and
Superman is like in terms of like volume
sold one piece is getting up there yeah
um but yeah I mean like the fan base are
very very dedicated
their very lifestyle it is a lifestyle
you don't read like you don't read a
thousand volumes or not I don't see it
as part of your identity unfortunately
yeah but I'm excited to see what you
think of like future arcs though I know
where it goes because my girlfriend she
binged all of it she's caught up yeah
like a thousand something yeah so I know
where it goes and I really like where it
goes the journey to get there is [ __ ]
miserable oh yeah I'm really uh knowing
your JoJo takes now I'm like fully
expecting you to just have the hottest
one please
like yeah I thought sky island was the
best dog uh seven was kind of [ __ ] yeah
I do agree that it does feel like the
characters are a bit Invincible at least
in the start not only that though I feel
like they're not changing like Luffy's
exactly the same right now where I am
that's what I said but apparently they
have on TV
it has been improving yeah I don't I
still don't like that no one dies like
even the I know like four major
character deaths I won't spoil anything
yeah but like you're past our law but it
took like a thousand chapters to kill
exactly like arlong doesn't die like
arlong's this terrible horrible man he
gets defeated by an ax kick never to be
seen again they talk about him like once
or something later on it's just that was
weird because like I remember reading
that part and I thought oh he's gonna
just pop pop back up because it doesn't
really feel like he was gone yeah and
then it just ended and I was like oh
yeah he didn't die he was incapacity
yeah yeah yeah yeah
to to counter it though to counter it
because I think because you know since
I've been a one-piece man for a long
time I remember having the same
criticisms about one piece being like no
no one seems to Die Why why there are
many opportunities for like a character
to die and then it just felt like he was
never gonna kill anyone off and then
when you get some of the first major
deaths you realize oh he's been saving
it for like this moment because those
moments like are [ __ ] iconic and like
anime and manga now and I think yeah no
I agree because I feel if you have a
manga that's going on for that long
especially yeah and you you've just been
constantly killing off characters after
the 20th death you're just going to be
like yeah all right what's the bet he's
probably gonna die again yeah so I feel
it gets overdone yeah yeah just thinking
that you could make the most iconic
character there but it still won't be
more iconic than the Tokyo Ghoul [ __ ]
panel
I'd tell you know the Rays like them you
know this no you know I don't think so
yeah I only watched Tokyo Ghoul one and
two
oh no it's uh it's it's it's in the
market
that's always on Twitter literally yeah
it was so weird because I finally got
the context of that for the first time
and it's a really serious it's a really
really serious seat but I like could not
take it seriously anymore because it's
just been I've just seen it so many
times it's like when you watch that
movie that you only know for the memes
and then you actually watch the scene in
context and you're like I know this is
supposed to be serious but I [ __ ]
hate that I can't take it seriously yeah